[Musique]
nous sommes la seule liste qui je crois
défendent ce que les français veulent
pour l'europe c'est à dire nous savons
que l'europe est nécessaire pour relever
les grands défis qui nous attendent pour
demain mais nous savons aussi que pour
que l'europe soit efficace au service de
notre destin il faut changer en
profondeur la manière dont elle se
construit
[Musique]
nous nous croyons à une europe qui
respecte la souveraineté la culture les
peuples nous croyons à une europe qui
trouve son juste modèle ni celui d'un
éparpillement de nations qui se font la
guerre ni non plus celui d'un empire qui
viendraient uniformiser tout sous une
forme de direction centralisée qui ne
pourrait être que technocratique
nous croyons que l'europe se
réconciliera avec les citoyens quand
elle reviendra au contact du terrain
quand nous pourrons ensemble sur les
questions d'agriculture d'économie
d'énergie sur les questions migratoires
faire ensemble de l'europe le lieu d'une
coopération efficace au service de nos
démocraties
[Musique]
nous restons fidèles à notre position
nous continuons de défendre ce que nous
avons toujours défendu au fond on voit
bien que dans cette élection aussi bien
un monsieur macron comme madame le pen
change de discours pour pouvoir
convaincre les électeurs
il ne faut pas se laisser abuser par des
changements stratégiques nous nous
croyons à la constance à la cohérence à
la clarté nous savons qu'il faut sans
doute ajuster modifiez transformez
certaines choses nous croyons que cette
europe que nous pouvons construire
ensemble que notre famille politique
peut construire au sein du parlement
européen de demain
le croyant qu'elle peut refaire la
preuve de son efficacité
[Musique]